Transcription: Manon Armenoult
Relecteur: Samira Kwache
« Soyez heureux. »
Imaginez qu’un matin,
votre patron ou votre manager,
vous accueille par ces mots.
Vous trouveriez ça bizarre.
Vous vous demanderiez
ce qu’il lui est arrivé durant la nuit.
Après, vous pourriez trouver plutôt sympa
qu’il se soucie de votre bonheur.
Mais vous pourriez aussi considérer
que cela ne le regarde pas.
Ces impressions contradictoires
viendraient certainement
de ce que cet impératif ressemble fort
à une injonction paradoxale.
Vous savez ces ordres
auxquels on ne peut obéir.
Quand le photographe
vous demande d’être naturel,
plus vous essayez, moins ça marche.
Avec le bonheur,
c’est un petit peu pareil.
Plus on vous demandera d’être heureux,
plus vous serez attentif
à ce qui ne va pas,
et moins vous le serez.
Alors, pourquoi parler de ça ?
Un patron ou un manager
qui donnerait l’ordre
à ses employés d’être heureux,
dans la vraie vie, ça ne s’est jamais vu.
Détrompez-vous.
Il existe aujourd’hui,
une mode managériale
qui vise le bonheur au travail
et qui, implicitement,
subrepticement,
presque sous la forme
d’un message subliminal,
exprime ce type d’injonction.
Mais, me direz-vous, où est le mal ?
N’est-ce pas une bonne chose
de vouloir le bonheur de ses employés ?
N’est-ce pas une intention louable ?
Certainement, mais n’est-elle pas
de celles dont l’enfer est pavé ?
Est-ce bien le rôle
d’un patron ou d’un manager,
de s’occuper du bonheur
de ceux dont il a la charge ?
A-t-il le droit de faire ainsi
intrusion dans leur vie ?
D’autant que le travail
n’est peut-être pas la chose
qui contribue le plus
à nous rendre heureux.
Alors, vous vous demandez peut-être
pourquoi je me pose toutes ces questions.
Il faut que je vous avoue quelque chose.
je suis philosophe.
Pas d’affolement, je ne vais pas
vous assommer d’un discours
qui va vous endormir
ou vous coller la migraine.
Moi, ce qui m’intéresse, c’est la vie.
Et c’est pour cette raison
que je travaille principalement
sur les questions d’éthique
et entre autres,
les questions d’éthique managériale.
Et certainement
parce que je suis philosophe,
je nourris un certain goût
pour l’authenticité
ainsi qu’une profonde aversion
pour les faux-semblants.
Et j’ai tendance à penser
que cette mode du bonheur au travail
cultive les faux-semblants.
Je vais vous expliquer pourquoi.
Tout d’abord, je ne suis pas certain
que bonheur et travail
aillent bien ensemble.
Parler de bonheur au travail,
n’est-ce pas comme parler
d’un cercle carré ?
Étymologiquement,
« Travail » et « Bonheur »
n’auraient peut-être pas
grand chose à voir.
Il se pourrait que « Travail »
vienne du latin « Tripalium »
qui désignait un instrument de torture
composé de trois pieux
sur lequel on attachait le supplicié
pour le travailler, le torturer.
Quant au bonheur,
il désigne le bon augure, la bonne chance.
On se sent pleinement heureux
lorsqu’on se sent en parfait accord
avec soi-même et avec le monde.
Or, n’est-ce pas parce que
nous ne sommes pas parfaitement heureux
que nous devons travailler ?
Car le monde ne s’accorde pas pleinement
avec nos besoins et nos désirs,
nous devons le transformer pour produire
ce qui nous est nécessaire
et que nous désirons.
Et, vous l’avez peut-être remarqué,
ça ne se fait pas sans peine.
C’est certainement pour cette raison
que dans notre civilisation,
le travail est perçu comme une punition
infligée par Dieu à l’être humain
après le péché originel.
« Tu gagneras ton pain
à la sueur de ton front »,
dit Dieu à l’homme.
« Tu enfanteras dans la douleur »,
dit-il à la femme.
Et curieusement,
c’est le terme de travail
qui est utilisé pour désigner
l'acte douloureux d'accoucher.
Rien de bien réjouissant dans tout cela.
D’ailleurs, travailler,
beaucoup d’entre nous s’en passerait bien.
Ils ne le font que pour gagner leur vie.
Pour Hannah Arendt,
philosophe du XXᵉ siècle,
qui a beaucoup réfléchi
sur la condition de l’homme moderne.
Le travail désigne ce qui nous rattache
à notre condition animale
parce qu’il consiste à produire
ce qui est destiné à être consommé,
c’est-à-dire détruit.
Il faut donc le produire à nouveau,
et cela indéfiniment.
La nourriture que nous produisons
par notre travail,
nous la détruisons chaque jour
en la consommant.
Il faut donc la produire à nouveau,
pour la détruire à nouveau,
ainsi de suite.
Et, comme notre société
est une société de consommation,
elle a intégré dans le monde du travail,
toutes les autres activités
pour devenir une société de destruction.
Aujourd’hui, tout est consommable :
les loisirs, l’art, les biens culturels,
et tout est fait pour accélérer
l’obsolescence de ces biens
afin de pouvoir les produire indéfiniment.
C’est certainement cela
qui explique le caractère
non seulement pénible
mais également lassant et ennuyeux
du travail humain.
Mais, me direz-vous,
le travail ne se réduit pas
à ces activités ennuyeuses et répétitives.
Il y a aussi les métiers dans lesquels
on peut laisser s’exprimer
notre esprit d’initiative,
notre inventivité, notre créativité.
Hannah Arendt répondrait :
« Oui, mais alors,
on n’est déjà plus tout à fait
dans le travail,
on est dans l’œuvre ».
C’est-à-dire, dans la création
de ce qui est destiné à durer.
Par exemple, vous inventez
une nouvelle technologie
qui sera encore utilisée
dans deux siècles.
Ce que vous avez réalisé, vous survit.
Vous avez réalisé une œuvre.
Vous élaborez une théorie scientifique
à laquelle on fera encore référence
dans le futur.
Vous avez fait œuvre de science.
L’artisan qui fabrique son ouvrage
crée une œuvre.
Mais c’est certainement dans l’art
que le terme d’œuvre prend tout son sens,
l’artiste dont les créations
ne se démodent jamais,
crée une œuvre.
Mais même lorsque l’on parle d’œuvre,
je ne suis pas certain
que le terme de bonheur
soit bien approprié.
Tant qu’on n’a pas compris
ou atteint la perfection,
on ne ressent pas
ce sentiment de parfait accord
avec soi-même et avec le monde.
C’est même l’inverse.
On se heurte à un réel qui nous résiste
et que l’on peine à saisir et apprivoiser.
En revanche, lorsque l’on sent
que l’œuvre prend forme,
on ressent un tout autre type
de satisfaction :
la joie.
Pour bien comprendre
ce qu’est la joie,
rappelez-vous quelques expériences
que vous avez certainement vécues.
Lorsque vous étiez élève ou étudiant,
vous avez certainement séché
sur un problème de maths
ou un sujet de dissertation.
Si vous êtes sportif,
vous avez certainement peiné
à réaliser certaines performances.
Si vous êtes bricoleur,
vous avez sûrement eu du mal
à réaliser certaines opérations.
Mais souvenez-vous maintenant
de ce que vous avez ressenti
lorsque vous avez enfin compris
quelle était la solution
de votre problème de maths.
Lorsque l’angoisse de la page blanche
s’est dissipée,
lorsque vous avez senti
que la performance allait se réaliser
ou que vous avez enfin compris
quel était le bon geste à effectuer
pour étaler l’enduit
sur le mur que vous rénoviez.
Vous avez senti votre puissance de penser,
votre puissance d’agir,
augmenter.
Vous vous êtes senti exister
plus intensément.
Vous avez ressenti de la joie.
La joie,
c’est cet affect que Spinoza,
philosophe néerlandais du XVIIᵉ siècle,
définit ainsi dans son Éthique :
« La joie est le passage de l’homme
d’une moindre
à une plus grande perfection »
Par perfection,
Spinoza entend puissance :
puissance d’être,
puissance de penser, puissance d’agir.
Je suis joyeux lorsque je me sens capable,
lorsque je sens que je peux réaliser
quelque chose de positif.
Et si la joie se distingue du bonheur,
c'est parce qu'elle est un passage.
Elle n’est pas la perfection,
elle est une progression
vers la perfection.
Tandis que le bonheur est un état,
un état de parfait contentement,
de parfait accord avec soi-même
et avec le monde
et qui tolère difficilement des degrés.
Je peux peut-être dire que je suis
plus ou moins malheureux.
C'est plus difficile de dire l'inverse.
On est heureux ou on ne l'est pas.
Et dès qu'on ne l'est plus tout à fait,
on ne l'est plus vraiment.
Le bonheur, c'est comme un horizon.
Il s’éloigne d’autant
qu’on s’en rapproche.
Il est cependant nécessaire
de le rechercher
car c’est l’occasion
de se procurer de grandes joies.
Et le travail peut y contribuer.
Certes, dans certaines conditions,
un travail ennuyeux
dont je ne perçois pas le sens,
ne pourra pas me procurer de la joie.
En revanche,
même s’il est pénible et difficile
mais que j’en comprends
l’intérêt et l’utilité,
il pourra me rendre joyeux.
Alors vous vous dites peut-être
que je joue sur les mots.
Bon, d'accord.
Joie, bonheur.
Il y a une petite nuance.
Mais ce n’est peut-être pas la peine
d’en faire toute une histoire,
au point de remettre en question
l’idée de bonheur au travail.
Seulement, les mots ont un sens
et qui est parfois lourd de conséquences.
La joie que vous ressentez
lorsque vous êtes au travail
ne concerne que l’activité
que vous exercez,
tandis que le bonheur met en jeu
votre existence tout entière.
Aussi, avec cette idée
de bonheur au travail,
ne risque-t-on pas de ne plus distinguer
entre vie professionnelle
et vie personnelle
et d’obliger chacun à privilégier
la première aux dépens de la seconde ?
Mon bonheur ne concerne que mon intimité,
il ne regarde que moi.
Aussi, n’y a-t-il pas avec cette idéologie
du bonheur au travail
- car c’est bien d’une idéologie
qu’il s’agit -
un risque de dérive
qui pourrait conduire à ce que
le monde du travail vienne s’immiscer
dans ma vie personnelle ?
Une idéologie, c’est un système d’idées.
Mais un système d’idées
à l’intérieur duquel
on veut faire rentrer de force le réel.
Pour l’idéologue, ce n’est pas aux idées
de s’adapter au réel,
c’est l’inverse.
Et gare à ceux qui ne rentrent
pas dans le moule.
Seulement, le problème,
c’est que le réel
est toujours plus complexe
que l’idéologie
et que c’est toujours violent
de vouloir le simplifier.
Mon bonheur ne concerne pas
que ma vie professionnelle.
Il résulte de l’interaction
d’une multiplicité de facteurs.
Aussi, même si j’aime mon travail
et que je le fais bien,
il y aura certainement des jours
où je ferais un peu la gueule
parce que j’aurai des soucis personnels,
financiers, sentimentaux, familiaux.
Ces jours-là, je ne serai pas
pleinement heureux au travail.
Néanmoins,
si ces soucis ne m’empêchent pas
de m’investir dans ce que je fais,
je pourrais en tirer de grandes joies.
Je me souviens, lorsque j’exerçais encore
le métier d’enseignant,
il m’arrivait de partir le matin
avec dans la tête des soucis
qui ne me rendaient pas heureux.
Mais quand j’arrivais dans ma classe
et que je commençais à faire cours
et que je voyais
dans les yeux de certains élèves
cette lueur qui exprime la compréhension.
Mais quelle joie !
Mais mes problèmes personnels
n’étaient pas réglés pour autant
et je n’en étais pas plus heureux.
L’idéologie du bonheur au travail
occulte l’ambivalence du travail.
Il est à la fois une contrainte
et une source de liberté.
Il est pénible mais peut être aussi
à l’origine de grandes joies.
Et cette complexité-là,
ce n’est pas en décrétant
qu’il faut être heureux au travail
qu’on pourra l’évacuer.
Les tenants de cette idéologie
ont inventé un nouveau métier,
celui de « Chief Happiness Officer »
dont la fonction est de veiller
au bien-être des employés
d’une entreprise ou d’une organisation
et aussi d’ailleurs de contrôler
s’ils sont dans de bonnes dispositions
pour s’accorder avec les cadres du bonheur
tels qu'ils sont définis
par cette organisation.
Et on retrouve là tous les travers
de l’injonction paradoxale
et du caractère intrusif
du bonheur au travail.
Seulement, quoi qu’il fasse,
ces chefs du bonheur,
ils ne parviennent pas
à faire du travail
une véritable source de bonheur.
Le plus souvent, ils ne font
que rendre plus confortable
l’environnement de travail.
Ce n’est pas en proposant
des cours de yoga
ou en organisant des apéros le soir
qu'on rendra le travail plus facile.
Le plus souvent,
ils ne font que créer une ambiance
superficiellement décontractée
à laquelle tout le monde
se soumet de plus ou moins bon gré
pour ne pas
mécontenter les collègues ou la direction.
Aussi,
pour mettre fin à cette tragi-comédie
du bonheur au travail,
Il vaut mieux mettre en place
un management qui crée les conditions
d’une véritable joie au travail.
Sans faire de cette joie
un impératif absolu.
Mais en aidant les personnes à mieux
comprendre le sens de ce qu’elles font
et en leur permettant de progresser
en percevant l’augmentation
de leur puissance d’agir,
ce qui est le véritable sens de la joie.
Par conséquent,
si un matin,
votre patron ou votre manager
vous demande d’être heureux au travail,
ne le contrariez pas,
il est peut-être sincère.
Mais faites-lui comprendre
que vous n’êtes pas dupe
et que votre bonheur ne regarde que vous.
Mais montrez lui aussi par votre attitude
que si le travail est parfois pénible,
il peut aussi
être source de grandes joies.
(Applaudissements)